[Music]
hello my mic is off to the side oh look
Rob showed up that's a zombie I guess a
copy it is World War two zombie but hey
guys looks angry put this away this guy
is real real in the way but uh hello
guys welcome to day two of the Call of
Duty private beta Call of Duty World War
two that poster was a kind of a sneak
peek because we have some posters give
away that poster that we just showed in
particular which is a Call of Duty World
War two zombies poster so if you're
interested in getting that you're gonna
have to follow a lot on Twitter and
retweet the tweet once Shiva the
controller of our Twitter tweets that
and you have a chance to win now the
only stipulation is that it only applies
in the US unfortunately so if you're out
of the United States I apologize but if
you want to tune in for that you know
and get that will drop some Twitter
links later but we're gonna get into the
game this is day two and I feel like
we've gotten wiser yeah we've gotten
more experience and we are out to kill
some people
Rob absolutely I'm ready I'm ready to go
to walk wet going to war
boots on the ground yeah boots on the
ground yeah we we've leveled up a little
bit here nice didn't get a chance to
play a whole lot last night but did play
a lot on the stream yesterday and a
little more afterwards yeah the more I
play this the more I kind of like it
Erica you feel nice to get back in a cod
because I never got into infinite
warfare fair I enjoyed myself but
obviously the more and more I played I
played a lot last night I'm not gonna
lie I played till like two I think last
night and the more I played it the more
it really just reminded me
of cod yeah no I know these notes
especially oh but then again I was only
playing team deathmatch because I was
just rying to get quick games in but
there is something I like especially
going back to the boots on the ground
experience where we're not just doing
all this crazy futuristic stuff right so
tone back it's that classic there's that
nostalgia there so I enjoy it for that
oh yeah that little short arm dude huh
I was gonna have to thank you guys all
for tuning in though I am checking out
the YouTube chat the twitch chat as well
I think we're also on Twitter today as
well as GameSpot so you guys have
questions I will try my best to answer
them or relay them to Rob so yeah we
appreciate you guys all tuning in TI
mine is on we're probably doing Mario
rabbits on next Tuesday when it on
launch day cuz we're gonna do destiny to
PC beta on Monday so that's kind of the
lysine schedule coming up soon
we are currently playing on ps4 because
that is the only way for you to play
currently that I believe Jacob Foster
already level 20 in the beta yeah we're
almost pony 20 is the max level of
course there's other things you can
level up though weapons as well as
divisions and I believe Rob is Airborne
Division I like the airborne
yeah the Airborne Division is unique and
good because you get a free attachment a
suppressor attachment and for some
reason and maybe they just wanted to
make it specific to division you can't
get that suppressor any other way right
which I find interesting and I was a
little sad about
yeah because I really wanted a
suppressor but it turns out I need to go
airborne
to get that surge suppressor at least in
the beta currently wasn't there you know
and what I would like is you know the
suppressors
is pertaining to the airborne class I
would like it if you could mix and match
like the suppressor is only where are
you the suppressor is only on smg's like
it'd be cool to like get creative with
like a sniper rifle right put it so each
class gets a their own right cuz like
the expeditionary class has incendiary
rounds but only for the shotgun so like
if I'm gonna use that class you know I
I'm kind of sticking to the shotgun yeah
I was using armored a little bit which
is primarily the LMG class and really
you just get the benefit of bipod which
is pretty good right but I just feel
like a lot of the current maps because
there's only three maps available and
this multiplayer beta outside of the war
mode right and so there aren't too many
times where I want to bipod up don't you
like because a lot of people are doing
what you're doing running around with
the SMG Kanaka especially in the close
quarters Maps yeah or something for
doing the quick scope snipe in here's a
little mini play the game this is kind
of new to have you guys didn't see this
yesterday it's only been broughten stars
too though for some reason there hasn't
been anything higher than that but maybe
that's just what's what is what is this
star I actually didn't I mean I saw the
Bronze Star iMac I don't know I think
it's just how they like rate it yeah how
long will the private beta lies I think
it's we can test that in a second to
Draco he says that if you're airborne
can't you put a suppressor on an AR and
I was like I don't think it's a
Bayonetta right pretty much it's like
the Earth's I would call it banana
bayonet I don't know why I keep saying
Bayonetta only if you're an infantry
class the infantry class go for the
bayonet right for the can only have a
bayonet if you have nice shooting if you
have if you have an infantry so you
can't use the bayonet on rifles if you
are infantry got it that's it
so yes next tech if you pre-ordered
for on ps4 you can get into closed beta
the other way is if you are a Comcast
subscriber or like you have the the
cable and oh no cable internet and
whatnot
you can call customer service apparently
and get a key that way as well so if you
have Comcast Internet I would yeah
that's all right
get to cover I'm not a huge fan of milk
Superboy I am like a little lactose
intolerant I don't know about you Rob
you like milk occasionally if I'm having
dessert I like a I don't like a cookie
or cold god damn it yeah with a cookie
little God cake some chocolate cake and
milk oh hey why not I'm gonna let you
focus a little bit you were you were
slaying yesterday once I stopped talking
to you so I stopped talking you you keep
going right yeah I keep going but uh you
know I you know I want to keep you on it
eyes on the prize okay so this first
weekend begins to 25th which was
actually technically was the 24th
because they dropped it early and ends
on the 28th at 10 a.m. the private beta
will resume September 1st at 10 a.m. on
both ps4 and Xbox one and ends September
4th at 10 a.m. Pt so that's the next
little private beta so again so Shiva
who is Khaleesi plays in Twitter has
dropped the are sorry in twitter has
dropped its Twitter link I will also
drop that in YouTube if one of our mods
hasn't so that you guys can retweet and
follow GameSpot to win that sweet zombie
poster zombie called Beauty world or two
poster
it looks pretty cool actually it's like
it's it's a lot more high quality than I
thought it would be yeah it's got a nice
little shine to it yeah a little gloss
yeah
[Music]
whoa those molotovs are interesting
that's a killer
yeah I like it
boss is good good I got care back so
we're trying to get so are you running
that that certain training yeah are you
pretty sure forget what it was called
exactly but you have different trainings
that you can pick one from and Rob is
trying one of the later tier 1 nope
depending on how you look at my level 19
it basically only gives you one of each
kill streak you have but you don't lose
the progression you've done on that kill
streak with this training when I die
yeah yeah when you die yes snapback
snotty I can't tell yet if there's gonna
be an open beta
unfortunately I let me see if there's a
generally RR I only see the note on the
like the Activision FAQ as like the two
private beta is the one that's happening
now and then the one that's gonna happen
in September that would include Xbox but
that still says private beta now you
know maybe that's just their terminology
I don't know if there's something you
owe you in that house somewhere well you
are you are in a spawn point let's burn
them burn them all says rave we could
try some expeditionary later rob the
shotgun kind of guy yeah I do I like
shotguns oh that's a nice little pro tip
d dark devil says you can shoot the
parachute from the care package to drop
faster no way I didn't know that that's
pretty cool no way
nice little next-level tip I always just
stare at it yeah Mon I know dude if
there's one thing the skin that gives me
the most anxiety it's definitely like
waiting for a care package to drop
cousin just the idea of someone stealing
it
gube when do you pick your division one
of the first things you do when you get
into the the beta multiplayer is it asks
you to choose from one of the five
divisions that doesn't necessarily mean
you're locked into that division but
you'll have to choose one to start right
and then as you progress you can unlock
one or one more every so often yes
basically like you can have multiple
loadouts with different divisions or you
could switch that loadout to a specific
division Rob is currently airborne which
gives him less suppressor on SMG I guess
you should double-check that and like
totally confirm for the the chat that
you can only put that suppressor on you
can do it and that's fine okay why don't
you show some of the yeah sure so we
were talking about airborne yep I click
here so there you go SMG suppressor
rifle ban has only four rifles LMGs
sniper sharpshooter I don't know what
sharpshooter is maybe just better aim or
something like that I haven't like hold
like hold breath maybe like you can't
hold breath and then shotgun only gets
the incendiary we got to try getting
those classifieds somehow I know I'm
pretty sure those are locked though I
don't know I don't know what else I just
I just unlock something go sparks anyone
like war mode Rob really likes war mode
I think it's a nice change for the Call
of Duty bring your shotgun oh yeah
perfect which one is it I haven't used
it yet so good time to toggle action I
thought that was like it like a
ambiguous name and then when you
unlocked a it would tell you but no
that's it that's the name of it tight
let's give it a shot comes a bazooka
again birkin Diller I unfortunately do
not know when the open beta will be
unless that next one that they're
calling a private beta is open
so we'll have to kind of keep our ears
to the ground or take a laundry and I
won't do that
just as a reminder we did put in a
twitch chat and also YouTube chat the
link to win to attempt to win that
poster that we had showed you earlier so
if you want to win that follow gamespot
on Twitter and retweet that tweet and
later today Shiva will be picking our
winners again that's only in the US so
apologies if you're not in the US but
yeah alright we doing some more
domination here we are this is a good
map I like this map I really like this
map oh yeah I'm really sick of Gibraltar
which is that other map I don't I just
got it a lot last night so alright here
we go
I didn't see I didn't see the stats on
this I have not seen this shotgun in
action so this one yeah the toggle
action I've seen a lot of the double
barrel oh okay
so far so good but those are inspire
rails fire rate was real fast okay
you're out of those good okay you got
it's a little margin you know that's
good stuff hurts burn him
like I think I think I'm gonna stay aim
higher yeah you gotta take head shots
right now I'm getting the itch for an
SMG someone want S&M SMB I'm a
search-and-destroy but I don't remember
seeing it
there's hardpoint there's domination
there's Team Deathmatch there's mosh pit
which is like a like a kind of like a
rule like a roulette of the multiplayer
modes and then there's war mode I'm not
sure that's Indies in this will check
for you later how's he not dead there
you go yeah I won't check the stats
exactly this feels like it has better
fire rate it definitely looks like it's
faster than the other two buying things
though is literally the people burning
it is they just yell for a long time and
even though you're like dead right like
you'll just see someone's body just like
kind of like and I think the other one
that's bad too is like watching your leg
get blown off from like artillery strike
oh you're crazy sir I know well I was
actually kind of an accident
oh okay Conte on a Kumu thank you for
the heads up there sharpshooter is
focused while holding breath yeah yeah
yeah dude this is my jam now I leveled
up the pistol last night from so on and
I got that a kimbos they're pretty fun
it's pretty fun to kill someone with a
pistol when they're using like an SMG or
something feels real satisfying oh I got
I got dial it back a little bit alright
you do you I'll be reading chat oh this
is an even more elaborate version of it
sharpshooter is this one block out the
surroundings and R in return acquire aim
assist and enemy names excuse me
activated while holding breath I wonder
if that's how it's how some of these
guys are crazily like doing the the
quick scopes cuz man last night I was
playing some some guys are like really
good yeah with quick scope sniping and
it's it's insane
nice this is the m1 garand it's good
solid gun single fire shoots decently
quickly it's a to tap Rob's also running
a rifle list I think is that I think
that's the basic training with this is
infantry Oh
allows you to hold rifle riflemen
rifleman sorry that allows you to hold
two primaries essentially I like it I
like to have that shotgun the second the
balance part of it though is that you
can't add attachments to your second
pile area so okay yeah
it was a good team we were up against
I'm also not playing all right you got
it you got off the SMG which is a good
staple oh there's a word you try to put
him
it's weird I didn't show you actually
budding him with the gun because he
definitely did that because you got a
hitmarker for it definitely all right
domination oh dude bayonet charges
precise mind have you got no fuel charge
we're like Oh God not the full charge
oh I charged someone and then stabbed
them and boy did it it lifted on them oh
yeah oh good night this is your name
that's mine that's that that's shotgun
back back up Sookie loving that shotgun
life it's a party in here thank you a
crazy Fame gamer for the like and sub we
appreciate it
[ __ ] house dumb that's another tactic a
lot of people are doing the stiff jump
SMG shot because it working well it buys
time right like it makes you miss maybe
a bullet or two so like if you're having
that one-on-one you have a higher chance
of winning obviously it's just a little
bit more skilled oh just like pulling a
juke you know just joking them yeah and
then also of course you know like quick
dropping and dolphin diving or in this
game as well so a lot of the good
players with the SMGs are just quick
dropping on people and they get into
those sprint fights insta dropping I
used to be decent at it I'm not as good
now I couldn't do it really last night
grenade yeah
it's not grand its grand I thought I
said grand if I didn't I apologize
because the UH
for the adjustment there no assure but
it is grand the Grant garand is grand
there you go that ping ping oh I enjoyed
that's a very satisfying sound to hear
it is
that's a good question dee dark devil
he's asking can you hear the footsteps
despite the background sounds being so
loud and I would say yes it is
distracting though to hear all the like
artillery and the explosions but if you
have headphones or earbuds in you can
definitely can definitely hear footsteps
it is a little distracting that with all
the noise but it I was able to kind of
hear footsteps last night I did have
earbuds in though a stroke it
unfortunately we don't have coats to
give away I only have posters as a
zombie poster Shiva our Twitter account
manager has tweeted tweets to win those
posters on line to follow GameSpot on
Twitter and retweet the tweet she'll be
picking winners today and we have some
posters to give away sorry we don't have
keys I'll try to see if we can get keys
for maybe the next stream I know we gave
some away on the site of previously but
I think those went real real fast again
if you guys have Comcast as a cable or
Internet provider just know that you can
um call call call them up call their
customer service up and get a key from
them apparently that's what I've been
told oh wow
the Winchester that is the Winchester
right I'm not yeah I think yeah yeah oh
my god okay
I see you well I was weird I kind of
saved my life
yeah what are you kneeling out there for
you ain't got no cover risque apparently
Beckham the eunuch at PS 33 says you
guys know if you download the beta from
Hong Kong PS store it is free no need to
preorder for the code I did not know
that if you guys want to try that that
is a tip from Beckham eunuch at PS 333
but if it doesn't work don't blame me
but thank you for that potential tip
nice shot there you can get a coat on
ebay definitely don't pay for it crazy
classics I'm not I'm definitely not
trying to be a big British person come
on fake British person what yeah cuz he
likes the UK presenters which is good we
love them - we love David I loved Lucy
tan they were set up to stream more I
would totally have them stream more but
it's just not currently in the cards but
you could potentially be that dude here
brash British action I don't really have
one Rob my table now I know I will not
because I don't want anyone yeah grind
their teeth Myles Levinson Garrick great
video guys thank you thank you
thank you in watching
do you feel this is a question from
Daniel Alexander a do you feel like this
action is or this match is quite that
based yes everything feels pretty
fast-paced so far in this multiplayer
beta most of the maps aren't very big
and nice little hip fire and warm while
it's still pretty fast but I guess it's
more methodical because you are moving
from destination to destination you do
need to do certain things like building
the bridge you probably want to have a
couple guys laying down smoke grenades
rather that you can you know do that
that's probably why Rob enjoys it-it's
just a little refreshing take from your
normal Call of Duty come on
you know yeah I love multiplayer yeah
it's it's more relaxing you feel like
you're having more of a like you're
involved more with your team find it
more true like a world war 2 experience
this is just totally Cod dark devil do
you agree that they should be putting an
XP bar at the bottom of the screen will
it be nice
why question why I guess basically
should they put the XP bar at the bottom
I mean they could I I've I don't know
for me personally I played so many MMOs
and stuff like that that it's not very
distracting for me I don't know if it's
distracting for other people but I guess
I wouldn't mind it it doesn't hurt I
guess not sure if they're going to
necessarily add it I guess have you only
paid two dollars for a codebook that
seems pretty good because you can get
three days to play but
I don't think Michael my Hardy is
reviewing rabbits unless I'm mistaken I
know it's a [ __ ] all right miss our boy
from Down Under
no Michael Hardy is just obsessed with
XCOM strategy turn-based type games
Christie I know that Kahn tells us the
XP at the end of the game but some
people are just saying they'd like to
kind of see that progression during the
game that's all
let's do war I think it's it's I think
XP bars have been kind of like yeah why
not like it's nice like there's a
feeling that you get that you see as it
goes it progresses the only thing that's
going slow is that for me I guess it's
not that bad though you gain like a good
chunk there I'm trying to level up
another divot Mountain Division which is
a sniper one and I only really wanted it
for the footsteps thing I don't even
want it for the Sharpshooter thing
because uh one of the one of the kind of
like perks so to speak of leveling up
the mountain division is that you do get
silent footsteps and I think you're also
one of the other ones is that like
you're not on the radar for recon I
think he's pretty good
EJ the dictator says war is the best
game mode I think I I mean I like it the
best this is my personal opinion yeah I
think you like it more too though like
now because it is different right
that's probably why Elan is real off
hopefully I said that right is there
gonna be a zombie beta gameplay as well
not sure there's no details in the other
closed beta that specify anything about
zombies so we'll see Lionel horse
package 9 Eric are you too excited for
destiny to be see pc beta and any
streams plan yes I am excited I think
I'm still gonna play on ps4 though
because that's where most of my friends
are and also because I don't want to
wait three weeks to just get going but
we will be playing the PC beta on Monday
me and John Luke when he's back from
quakecon and we plan to stream destiny
to post launch every Tuesday so if
you're into destiny stuff
I wanted to Nate and join us please do
so we're gonna also take advantage of
that clan system get a game clock plan
going
so when that happens I'll fight you all
all the destined to players that want to
join the GameSpot clan to join that try
to do some night falls together and
whatnot but yeah looking forward to that
too Matt Falcon I can't believe I'm
super hype for a cod game for once now
now I love the MW mana warfare trilogy
in chair games but this one looks great
yeah there's something about kind of
going back to your roots you know and
feels good feels good sorry Edward
Kenway I don't have any codes we do have
a poster giveaway though you guys are
interested in that poster sorry no keys
though you can try that thing that the
one gentleman in YouTube chat mentioned
try going to the Hong Kong PlayStation
Store and downloading it that's weird
if it works it works man or if you're a
Comcast customer you can try getting it
from their customer service that way too
I don't know the details of the clans
stuff too much jet food sorry what he
was like in that little roundabout with
you hello Dale pull it
welcome welcome to come back a fire yeah
yeah I think that's one of the perks I
have on spray-and-pray
baby do you know if you still have that
training on the one to get the parents
yeah I do that's that's I'm gonna play
this one for now on our course you need
a slave hey guys straight slay all right
nice mic mics go so sponge you should
take a cue from fortnight and link the
accounts for ps4 and PC to share
progress that's tough
cuz I don't even know if there's gonna
be chronic behind you because I don't
even think there's gonna be cross play
so I don't think there's a reason to all
so the interesting thing about that -
not thinking about it is that destiny is
on battlenet right or the blizzard app
and even currently for Diablo 3 even
though it's on console as well as PC
those things aren't shared so I don't
see that happening
get that stupid guy hitmarkers for days
that guy's gonna come around the right
huh now behind you
I like the patients though I do you got
a recount recall your plane when you
need it later
kind of looked like he was gonna come
out - yeah you had a guy - you're right
kind of covering that flank when is the
release date if you're asking about the
release date for COD is November 3rd I
don't know
see sometimes I think I like have enough
helped get away and like have another go
at it dude it's caught you don't ever
have a head no no way I know she just
hit stood your ground and tried to hold
B that's tough yeah you know what a lot
of us have having played so much
titanfall because that is a solution
always this is a good question and one
that I think it's like you know
frequented for like cod games across the
board would Brown proud 23 do you guys
think the time to kill is too fast in
this game could the game afford to give
everyone a little bit more health I
would instead I think that would be a
good thing I wouldn't mind a little bit
more health may be another like one
extra shot to kill or something because
sometimes it feels like you just have no
chance but part of that to me too is
like in playing so many cod games it's
like you think you had a chance but then
if you look at the replay like in the
latency you'd never had a chance right
so I don't know that's my opinion on on
life I guess having a little bit more I
think would be nice what about you up I
think it's fine it's just it's the game
like it at some point it becomes like
unrealistic right and you want to
imagine you're playing like a wart
licker you're in World War two to some
degree below
yeah good avenging I think you're gonna
get the paratroopers oh no you're not
yeah where are you guys oh my god
use your recon you'll find out thank you
for Langley not bad timing on my part my
fault no Ilan is real off asking about
probably the destiny to beta because he
says most of the his friends play on PC
you have any information about the PC
beta yes I believe Monday is a closed
beta like early kind of like an early
access beta for those that pre-ordered
the game and I think on Tuesday it
becomes open beta I forget how many days
it is exactly but that's kind of the run
of the mill so you should be able to do
that Caitlin Webb GameSpot any confirmed
view modes the only confirmed new mode
currently in the multiplayer beta is war
mode which is a new mode where you're
kind of pushing or defending different
objectives oh yeah sick great hot tip
their dark devil who woke up here
troopers oh you did yeah all right this
is the one kill streak we don't really
know much about ours I don't let's get
it I'm imagining you to Mobile Suit okay
so what happens we're it okay sir we're
trying to look at paratroopers oh oh do
I get straight-up AI it looks like it oh
this is pretty good for domination this
is like that uncharted stuff you just
call an AI type should take C while your
paratroopers are they kind of split up
to they just go do their own thing but
they I'm a gang I guess you could have
shot the parachutes down faster I don't
know if you want to do that to someone
why not they're just AI pro I know
that's true
yeah Caitlyn was called war mode you
push or defend different objectives
come on nice and we can show you guys
that mode in a little bit Rob lit enjoys
playing it so I don't think it's gonna
be a hard-ass - oh come on you did get
that guy it was the other guy that
killed you so you almost got a nice
little double there though yeah yeah
sometimes to learn honor it's tough
sometimes you miss a little bit you you
have to use a whole clip but uh you know
I think one of the best tips I can give
people that are playing called you the
first time and I still do it I still
make the mistake of doing it myself is
try not to reload every but yes you
think you need to because this game is
so fast-paced that if you reloaded like
right there
you wouldn't be ready to fight that next
guy and some and you don't need that man
bullets to kill someone so you're better
off not spamming reload just after like
one kill that would be like a tip I was
dog if you're just getting into Cod or
reloading in the open like that would be
the other thing I find myself doing by
accident like I should have done that
might reload in the open horse package I
mean you can still get headshots in this
game so you can still kind of get those
one-shot kills because I was doing it
with the pistol last night he just hit
it at the right spot you'll get a
headshot
you saw your stupid camel helmet Oh what
sniper
cao lau i don't know if there's gonna be
an open beta weekend like it was for
black ops 3 an infinite warfare there
hasn't been anything announced the only
things that are going on are this
current private beta and then that other
one I mentioned on September the 1st
well this has got good spot that that
would be ps4 and Xbox one but it says
private beta which this one's called
that too so I don't know if that's
closed or open so we'll see
Fernan docks 28 yeah beta already
started on ps4 it started yesterday
actually dropped early do you guys know
any information about the PC beta if
you're talking about Cod I don't know
anything about the PC beta for that no
you know it's interesting exam is like
something you'd always want to there are
certain games are like this there's
another one I can't remember offhand but
like if I'm gonna play war mode I'll
tell you what I would not want is this
requisition one oh you know what I mean
there are cup dammit ok forgot to cancel
or I'll do one more these are the more
and then we'll go to yeah you know I
mean because there's no kill streaks in
war mode there's another one that is
kill streak related or something else
we're like I don't know you you would
want to have a class if you're doing
custom classes you want a class doesn't
it from one fo-fo code this is not
pre-recorded I just saw your message
therefore not pre-recorded laughs baby
was he trying to throws no he was wait I
stunned it you stun it okay it just
looked like you he was like mid
animation alright so they're taking age
should have died there yeah yeah yeah
all matter needs yup you didn't think
she had an enemy reloaded reloaded I did
it that's alright it's a it's a habit
it's a it's a tough one to fight
I always have to try to fight it but I
catch myself doing it too
like you would
is that an LMG I just picked up and I
think he picked up the type 100 when you
flash it for a hot second so I couldn't
tell come on Eric yeah
Lionel horse package 9 saying sorry this
question his ass has been asked but can
you get all the benefits of this game by
simply playing Cod world at war or does
this feel different than that jeez it's
been a while since I played call it a
world war but that you know I initially
did get a lot of like God a lot of
nostalgia for that game I played a lot
of world at war but I don't know that's
that's a good question to be honest it's
been a while for me as well yeah like I
wouldn't be able to like remember
exactly how that damn how that game like
worked I mean that was still very much
caught right like all the like picked 10
I believe that that was a no honey dog I
never reload you're gonna have to reload
at some point yeah you're crazy but look
I'm sure it looks better
Oh got him nice kappa dick happy how
does this handle and does it feel as
good as two or three love you work love
part your love your work by the way
thank you for the nice words and let Rob
can answer that what was I'm sorry well
how does this handle and does it feel as
good as two or three I guess in warfare
um again I think that's another question
of like I just don't I don't know feels
I think it's good yeah like it's not
like it's too different
I think if you're I think that
experience is very similar yeah except
for that weird it's really stiff jump
but I'm sure that existed yes super
stiff jump
well there's mantling in this to danda
probably didn't exist in those game yeah
one x have an upgrade I want to say I
think that nice this does feel he tried
a tried it you guys a little get done
you look so done when you do that yeah
but it's an effective strategy though oh
absolutely
legit cuz I have died those guys that do
the job back dick I almost didn't see
him yeah I don't know how you do it with
that iron sights on this one this one's
tough I use the I really like those
perks so I try to like I try to tell
myself oh yeah you'll just get better
with iron sights but mopping it up with
the grease gun oh hell yeah
when was that guy gonna fire oh god he
got like five killer jeez and we're pro
600 I'm glad you're about to play the
game but try not to self-promote that
goes for everyone in judge
does that actually work what self remote
yeah sometimes but I don't know I mean
I'd have to ask them if it works or not
you can see it so often I feel like yeah
you see these glasses every day correct
I did like the quick stop the quick stop
would build the animation of the reload
right right yeah I mean I was just
trying to kill that animation yeah yeah
you're like I should never you loaded
should've done that they're gonna come
from everywhere that backside here oh
wow it resets if I walk away that's real
dumb kind of a blow that brand you love
the grand you too I got off the garand
last night oh really cause I was trying
to like oh he blended in pretty nicely
the old lay on the floor tactic pretend
like it did I started using other guns I
used a lot of SMGs though I started
using the type 100 which is the third
SMD it doesn't do as much damage as this
one but it has more range so that that's
the kind of a benefit of that as a me
Baker's lost who's gonna make our bread
and stuff I loved it what's with the
slow-mo uh the only thing I can think of
when you're talking about that is when
he gets stunned
perhaps yaks stun grenade nade or
concussion grenade or something yeah he
stood on that as we speak
give me a kill please I didn't know
you're gonna come Hong Kong katana I
haven't bought cod since black ops 2 so
don't see a reason to buy it now yeah I
mean if you've gotten off the cod train
unless like a bunch of your friends play
multiplayer it's definitely you know I
could see why you would have dropped off
a little bit there falling off it's a
cod train I mean I only used to I only
kept playing Cod up until maybe infinity
no not in black ops 3 because I had a
lot of friends on ps4 burning cod that
you know like that's alright like we're
gonna hang out play some card chat a bit
have a good time and then once they kind
of stop playing or like once I actually
started playing destiny I kind of got
off I kind of got off the train too I
mean I still enjoy it from time to time
but I definitely don't haven't binge Don
it like I used to I mean the other thing
you really want to consider too is like
the single-player
oh that slope shotgun I really wanted
you to be at them oh okay
do that now only if you have a chance
don't force it so the bayonet the good
thing about the bayonet is it is a
one-shot kill I'm like the push the
little push the gun but that doesn't
kill people in one shot oh you're smart
I like the idea
god I gotta stop thinking I can do
things this jackass whoo yeah so he had
the type 100 ya capo de Kaffee single
player should be pretty good they're
usually solid experiences especially on
bright in the legs so it'll be
interesting to see what do you know what
part of the war they're covering have a
kind of it's I think it's like d-day
invasion so it's like one campaign the
East Western how did that not kill how
am i alive no I'm in real I know but
like yeah that was that was weird it's
like almost like you're gonna win here
it was he was really close I think it
wasn't what it really was
but yeah I believe it's it's an infantry
division so it's like d-day landing and
I think it's um I don't know
yeah jaunty Bray I mean Aaron Sampson
one of our other video producers on the
pit was just complaining about how stiff
it was yesterday now I don't know it
didn't feel that bad to me but I guess
I'm just kind of gameplay style I didn't
think anything of it personally but if
you've been playing other more like
fluid games like titanfall 2 or like
those kind of games where movement is
like you know more of them the emphasis
is more on movement then yeah I can see
how you could feel that this game is a
little bit I like it just be safe
yeah there ain't no there ain't no
friendly fire remember to back out hello
Andre Sutherland from Costa Rica thanks
for tuning in says you guys don't think
the running movement is wonky you run
fine steps and the dude stops annoying
that bothers me a little bit but I think
you're supposed to level up the like
perks and stuff like that to gain more I
think more sprint and indeed crystal
clear says the western front so yeah if
you guys forgot or didn't see at the
beginning of the stream we are giving
away a call of duty to Zambia
Call of Duty World War 2 zombies poster
it looks pretty cool I'm posting the
link in YouTube chat right now if you
want to win that you need to follow
GameSpot on Twitter and retweet it and
if you're lucky and in the United States
you have a chance of potentially winning
today and I think I have like a image I
have an image kind of looks the face
looks like that I can kind of try to
unroll it here see you guys
range so the poster pretty much looks
like this
looks good it's pretty good if you're if
you're into zombies this is a pretty
cool poster so yeah we're going to wall
oh alright nice this is that new mode
we're talking about war mode so we check
that out
whew that's a tough name to say Rikuo
Beck sole a asking do they still have
loadouts
yeah more or less this is like a that's
a loadout right there yeah yeah so you
pick your division you pick your weapon
potentially your secondary oh we're
already mid fight yeah it's like your
team is on the push this is the second
part right after the headquarters part
yeah this is the last part oh there's a
last part sorry sorry they got past
blowing up the ammunition area so this
one's tough to get by if they're smart
and they're on the turrets that you have
to build which is also kind of something
new it's like think zombies where you
know you're building them barricades but
here you're building you know turrets
and and and barricades okay yeah and
very good level up level oh hey oh damn
it
the Eco ran did you guys try this guy
what's up Naza Sarah welcome to the chat
I got a steel drum here on this thing
the poster looks like a cool poster
because it's gross and disgusting so
it's a cool poster
what's the reason you're giving it away
just because you know we're appreciative
of you guys watching and tuning in and
we want to give some stuff back when we
can't and it's topical because we're
also streaming
so oh he's got that flamethrower oh oh
happy just tarik Ram Johnny World War
two or nuke losses for you guys I you
know I think that's tough I haven't
played any more new Colossus so and kind
of different games to write once so
heavily single-player babe the tree the
tree to tree yeah where else I don't
know oh yeah yeah yeah I don't know how
he doesn't see there's one in the the
church too good run how did you know
would it there there was there someone
on the office opposition that was
holding you back man it must have been
at like 98 oh we are not retreating
great
get in
oh yeah boom down so close mom all down
come on y'all it's close six seven eight
BAM all right see if that works
yeah I'm real tired of that one guy just
being a real jerk
I don't mind any constructive criticism
guys but you guys don't need to spew
toxicity in our chat hmm just so you
know I will timeout or bad people but I
appreciate all the people that are
actually joining in on a good
conversation asking questions amen I
appreciate all of you guys very much
be honest John's now with IVA you Eve Co
I've been saying your name wrong sorry
the suppressor attachment is specific to
the Airborne Division and specifically
for SMGs currently in the game I have
not seen a suppressor on anything else
but the SMGs and that specific division
so if you're trying to use and a
suppressor that's the only way they're
gonna sneak on the left for infantry you
get the bayonet attachment which is what
Rob has on his m1 garand and for LMGs
which is I'm armoured division it can be
by potted
oh that guy like I want this fight look
at Robin sneaky it's really really
holding it down here welcome Oh welcome
welcome to our headquarters Oh a new
guest yeah come on in
Steve 994 how do the weapons feel I like
them I like I think that you know you
find the gun that you like I think the
most popular ones so far that I've seen
are the PP I forget ppsh PPSh SMG or the
type 100 SMG I've seen a lot of people
use the the SE gr the SDK stg44 is the
German thing a snake already bad and the
m1 garand is pretty nice it's a pretty
nice solid yep C solid solid
oh you're liking the expeditionary - for
close quarters without the incendiary
shotgun bullets yeah you want to
barbecue your opposition your ski risky
risky maybe they won't see you let's
party
this is one Rob's at his best when he's
on the edge this isn't saying much it's
so fun weren't that guy going crazy Oh
wrong time
so can you create your own class yeah
you kind of can in a way you have to
pick one of five divisions and then just
because you picked that division doesn't
mean you're locked into using a specific
gun but there are also there are
obviously perks kind of geared towards
certain divisions so you know obviously
the suppressor for SMG for airborne the
bayonets for the rifle as well as there
was the sharpshooter hurt for those
pipers
yeah so weird build a gun you guys set
it up it just you know I think it's more
that your buddy
oh so we lost the first objective here
so speakers our first offense point so
now the game pushes you back to the
bridge where the enemies here have to
rebuild the bridge so Dom you're just
gonna get shot like that that's when you
turn around a fire I guess now we camp
them though Rob I let's we do some
sniping uh yes
Lucas heel of Marat beta beta lost a
host connection I think are there any
akimbo they ask yes I was able to get
the pistol kimbos which you have to
unlock it weapon level 8 that's how long
I use the pistol oh really it's it's
pertaining to the actual Wow and you
have to use a special if you go to your
divisions real quick you have to use a
bait a specific basic training so if you
can go to the basic training for me
before this I had to use duelist which
allows you to have attachments on a
secondary otherwise your pistol will
never have an attachment and the other
thing about the akimbo is that's
slightly unfortunate is that even though
you have two expansion slots for the
pistol with duelist you can only
okay blow if you can't do it if you have
anything else equipped so I can't have
extended mags or anything like that hmm
she's unfortunate I think that's been
the case in the past yeah I know but
it's just like and I really wish I could
have more bullets or something right
yeah that was a quick look at the
character screen black barbarian we can
kind of take a longer look in a little
bit yeah or all the maps is small so far
yes sousou's e02 for gaming all the cod
multiplayer maps so far in this beta
sands this war mode are all roughly that
size you guys have seen crypto says how
we doing today I'm doing pretty damn
good it's Friday happy Friday happy
Friday's right yeah the Draco seven can
we see an infantry class within SMG in
stock if you have it unlocked okay we're
gonna do we can make that later you got
it here we go we're we're positioning
and reloading the gun so it's not like
we necessarily yep I see it I always
like hardcore mode do you though yeah I
do I think it's fun I would have been a
salt bag right there okay like you would
have killed him right there does
hardcore mode I would have I guess
that's why I like it is that from the
wine cellar no you gotta have a guy in
the wine cellar you do it is key because
there's only so many places they can get
in you're in serious as a wine cellar I
think I call it the wine so whatever
that thing is to the right there
wherever that oh I call that the wine
cellar I don't know if it's an actually
wine no actual wine cellar console hot
92 am I the only one that pronounces
ACOD not cod I
but I sure I've heard people say Co D
you co saying hardcore in club now get
some around oh I hate when the Oh that
screwed me up when the explosion went
off oh hi guys oh yeah did he get him
with the piston no he tried to you try
to piss the woman lost uh yeah what's
with the maps they look so small
those could just be the maps they want
for this beta like put more clothes for
ya never know
I would say that if you're looking for a
world war game with big Maps you
probably wanna play battle but I prefer
the small the medium maps I think this
is a good sized map this one is for I
mean it is also but this is a very
specific mode right it's still kind of
small if you think about okay All Right
see you later
dammit I know I know it
JK lol I'm not sure if the PC version
will have dedicated servers or officious
matchmaking why this that's been like
host oriented right I crazy for thinking
I don't know actually
just like I've gotten that hosts
migrated thing before okay that makes
sense so there are air drops in this
game let's do this in this yeah [ __ ]
what do you get on this side oh you got
a plinth okay and then what do you get
on the other side or do you guys think I
can't remember but the cool thing about
the flamethrower is as you guys
mentioned before you don't lose it if
you die you just get X amount of ammo
let the flamethrower
first one no you're not getting on that
turret oh wow you get so much more
visibility of stuff on this side that's
a grenade I am yeah I really don't have
as much but it that definitely there's
two turrets he was in the left one
there's one on the right and it's pretty
tough to get past both and try to build
the bridge cuz you're still exposed when
you're building the bridge oh they're
building it they're trying to get up on
that bridge dang it
happy Friday y'all cheers tarik ramzani
World War 2 going to be my first Cod
since first black ops first black ops
was solid though really like for black
ops a good move returning their 1940s
yeah I think she would agree it's weird
how like we went from this phase of we
want futuristic shooters and I'm now
like going back and like not wanting
that anymore and just want any more of a
boots on the ground it's this guy's got
the right idea is yeah so yeah this is
where you need to lay down smoke to
really get through this objective
because otherwise you're gonna get
destroyed but Rob knows this and he's
just picking them off oh yeah maybe if I
crawl up to this what sorry for yelling
yeah you're good I would have felt the
same way you should have got more than
10 I feel like I see him
this is dumb still huh oh that's good I
can do it from prone oh yeah baby
we should bait it and just use your
normal gun
Oh get rekt sorry dude he's got such an
advantage there I know but that's why I
was saying user grande brain I am oh oh
you did their philanthropy I who is Ben
djenka out in our video pit I feel very
confident in saying that I believe the
series peak with black ops one I don't
know man why don't warfare my worker too
is real good stuff there but their black
ops one was good to shred oh yeah come
back on a peak I can't get an angle
there yeah you need the other guy the
other guy sees all that though so you
should be hosing hosing that down like
right now legit you should be hosing it
down dang like I went back that's the
thing is they know right where you were
well this is this is the part to where
you're switching classes right you're
switching like if they're attacking
they're trying to switch to snipers
because they have to kill the people in
these little nests to provide cover for
the people that are trying to build a
bridge because they just get slaughtered
like that otherwise Rob's in work yeah
like I like where this guy's head that
you just right up in the biz what a
badass this guy's a KGB ass the KGB are
up in this oh man I wish that was my dad
Robin Hood saying I like changes I'm
curious to see other maps definitely see
how many war mode maps there are and how
those things change these use different
flavors right you're like holding the
point you're doing a sketch escort the
payload essentially right they could get
pretty creative with it I'm hoping for -
I have daddy issues no I'm hoping for
you got it nezam I got it now what was I
gonna say I'm hoping for yeah or like
different types of objectives I would
not like to see the same series of
objectives you know what I mean well
yeah like was like repeated every map
alright here we go
I'm sorry Robin
Zombies I hope they do something
different hoping I hope they dial back
though like just like did we see zombie
fit like the trailer sorry
I've seen some zombie stuff but it
wasn't like true zombies I don't think
that guy's crazy he was crazy
oh so you know okay so for those curious
he Rob's got the extended mags on this
on this SMG right now which is giving
that little drum barrel underneath which
is like great because this is like how
you don't you kind of stop yourself from
reloading right knowing that you have so
much ammo to dump right got him and
you're still reloading after we just
said yeah I was like right totally and
then there I go and do it at least the
reload time is quick dude the LMG reload
time oh so slow it is yeah I quite
literally the wars sorry I got nervous
for you cuz he's a shotgun
look he's an expeditionary oh you so
that's the gas mask for that yeah yeah
that's the other fun thing I'm looking
forward to now it doesn't really play
into gameplay but I'm curious to know
and see what other types of costumes
they have or you know outfits oh right
right right now you're just kind of
stuck using basic day one stuff but I'm
sure there's gonna be a bunch of
different outfits right cuz that you
know part of me is like oh man the gas
mask guy okay guy is kind of cool any
kind of but I wonder you have some my
ear I wonder if you like
what cool
I wonder if man that was a real nice
situation I'd ruined it I wonder though
if you can't change the gas mask and
it's only pertaining to like the class
just to like do that visual difference
okay I'm sure the gas mask will stay for
the extradition area probably the outfit
or the just like little pieces of a time
exactly when is the giveaway snack
Mike's naughty basically it's gonna go
on until probably the end of the day and
if you retweet and follow GameSpot
you'll have a chance to win of course as
long as you're in the United States
that's the main caveat so yeah
Shiva will pick winners later I think
you guys need a link I can also try oh
so you can't Oh what I get the idea so I
don't I kept thinking I had to like get
onto the bridge but you slowly advanced
the building yeah yeah I didn't get that
yeah yeah no I thought I had to get on
the bridge I could've been building
their hilarious cuz yesterday like four
or five of us like late in the day
yesterday we're playing war mode
together I'm like guys get on the bridge
we gotta build it give me smoke please
thank your sniping oh my god I just to
build this bridge so that other thing I
was mentioning earlier this is where you
really want smoke you really need to
smoke the bridge and
just try as much to buy time I don't
have any I had this but I want to snap
okay then you snipe and hope that the
rest of you okay you do your team that's
why whoa
yep
Hey no yeah I'm smoke yeah later look
down he's gonna be back Rob will play
the wicked
it doesn't matter what state in the
United States it's just a you us that's
all so yeah as as mentioned prior it's
key here to not only have that smoke but
also have the snipers just taking out
the turrets taking out other snipers
because those guys are just basically
gonna sit and camp on these uh these
turrets which I would do to it was kind
of robbed we're having sadistic laughing
whoops
while we oh my god that one and he had
the left house I had the right house
we're just like these guys don't know
what to do where are you at I know that
guy once get back on the turret where
are these guys I know no one's being a
hero building a bridge like they should
be and you got one minute
oh all right let's prep be a hero let's
be a hero yeah every time I Swan I
literally just jumped at the bridge like
you know got killed just kept holding
down yeah yeah so you want to get icy
it's tough so tough tough without cover
you have no cover
yeah well the smoke and your teammates
are your whole hope for that okay see
how this guy just got out she's got want
a baby just got it yup hold it they
don't see me they don't see me they
owned your no pile of dead bodies this
is the best play right oh my god you're
right dan heard all those snipers oh
yeah this guy's having fun
wouldn't you yeah this is pretty tough
part to break though if you're not
coordinated with your team
look at you using your pistol all right
yeah seven seconds seven seconds here we
go there's two of you me they don't see
me Oh get on the bridge boys last chance
oh you get it Wow nailed it
of course when you blaze that bridge
yeah we got 420 plays that bridge all
right so now the next part happens phase
three we got to destroy their ammo dump
essentially by planting a bomb do you
feel that guy okay yeah sorry I was
looking at you how many people have to
die to build this bridge apparently a
lot very many all right we're doing it
smoking it up so here the enemy team
could build up these walls that kind of
prevent you forgetting staying because
you need to ultimately get in there to
arm the bomb and they can defuse it
so someone tried to plant it that's not
good okay okay he's on the tank
interesting it's kind of hoping that
that wouldn't happen to me after seeing
that guy burn it did oh there is there's
sometimes I've seen I've been artillery
and then my I just see my leg
missing on the floor came from behind
he was waiting he was playing the
waiting game where was he he was hiding
him there in that room [ __ ]
stop in it I know I'm sorry Eric feel
like I just charged you like a dollar
every time you reload that's pretty
steep oh come on this guy expeditionary
man areas for him to succeed here that's
that a division I should play that
division a little bit more on that I've
never been a huge shot gun guy but it
feels pretty good it feels like it could
be pretty good Snape's don't mind me
here we're building a wall here yeah
look away the Draco seven is their only
gonna be one map for war launch no idea
I'm really hoping there's a couple maps
and like Rob mentioned too we're hoping
for some variety and not just like
here's the headquarters and then now you
have to you know we're hoping for some
variety and not just kind of like
another matter this guy
some wow I like it
oh this guy's spamming his shotgun
please reload yeah we're good
yeah this is this is time this is time
is that a good time to reload oh man
it's got rocket launcher in it sick dude
I wanted to do that thing wow I'm alive
no not good dolphin dive whoa C++ what
level are you I think it's 19 yeah 20 I
think is maximally new I'm 19 as well
not years old but not on my watch we
ain't guys Bowl today nice
good read advancing yeah yeah yeah yeah
nothing can stop our tank that dude man
that guy he is on fire so that blank
master that guy yeah he really is
he likes flank steak no way like not
like any guys steak oh this dude I think
flank steak is good when it's like you
know in stock yeah there you go
fine like that but like I had a choice
that would not be my first choice I
don't know how old we get crazy here
okay crazy no I want something else
long range ain't no one third a sport
[ __ ] this objective based gaming Rob I
know but I was trying to what's up
Andrew mccurdy trying to get that gunner
alright this is the toughest part that's
what we're doing yeah James formalize
the point you could pre-order anything
canceled that's also a way to get in oh
I saw some of your innards get tossed
around Davos I need covering fire
those damn oh you got someone with that
tax support
oh he's trying oh that's a good dis guys
shoots the flamethrower you can't see
them yeah that's true all right all
right I think we're good yeah it's gonna
be tough it's still very they just push
it back all right
okay you got you got some guy laying
down the fire there damn it he's behind
the wall
that one's hard this that that a deed
roller church-like you can't and I think
the only way in it for you guys is from
the front
I was a guy right there oh yeah oh I
thought he was rock he did look like a
rock he was head glitching that's good
rice gets by it this is the toughest
part
final push there 40 seconds we'll see if
we get there hopefully we do yeah use
your strong arm Rob such a dead place
just climb over I shut up
okay 18 seconds last time you guys have
like less than two seconds and you guys
made it
oh here he comes he's barbecuing some
people he's been waiting this whole time
like yeah everyone wants to push this
tank huh I got a little little barbecue
for you
did you already play both sides on this
I think we flip okay yeah GCP tummy time
we trying to put in that work that Call
of Duty World War two which are joining
a network I'm not Mike
wait this isn't Food Channel yeah I wish
making us hungry it's almost lunchtime
for us dude I'm sorry twenty five six
yeah come on Rob I mean uh oh that was
it
I was seasick Valis k-- asking what is
the best gun so far I think it depends
on your preference obviously I am G s
have definitely been kind of a staple
the SG stg44 is pretty solid if you're
good at quick scoping the sniper is
pretty good mm-hmm
but I've seen a lot of a lot of SM DS I
did the second man third we do something
else sure when we go out on whatever
last one you want LMG Farrelly's
I don't know man I was not having the
best success with it I mean unless you
can out gonna well maybe my play style
doesn't lend itself well to LMG I don't
like waiting around so yeah what is
tactical I take extra tactical extra
like us like a stun grenade and yeah two
frags so like you get nominates huh I
haven't tried it yet I've seen someone
use it I was like damn this guy's
spamming and then I realized he had bang
and basic training yeah
um sorry I'm stalling okay let's do what
do you want to do let's get crazy and
use some moshpit huh see what happened
that one that you thought was an actual
game type but it turns out it's just
either team deathmatch domination or
hardpoint yeah it just rotates actually
I should play that mode more cuz it's
like it gives you you know different
flavors you know Jojo presses is it
divisions good um I mean they're kind of
like classes in a way so they're
breaking it up that way and you can't
really tie those perks around [ __ ] it
make you think about your play style
like selectively you know what I mean
like it kind of it kind of like maybe if
you think you're yourself is like a
shotgun king you kind of well-known on
this game nas I think at some point
you'll probably able to change some of
the clothing I'm sure something will
still look distinct like the expedition
Ariel Christ I'll have some type of gas
mask but right now in the game there's
only like one kind of look for each
division so we'll see if they
incorporate other stuff come launcher
down the road where are these buttheads
Shantay gosh it's too hard for me to
tell you if it's worth buying because we
haven't played single-player at all and
we're only playing multiplayer I think
that for me I always look at it this way
at least with Call of Duty games is that
if you enjoy Call of Duty games enjoy
the multiplayer then chances are you're
probably gonna buy this one especially
since it's back to its kind of
background so to speak but I don't know
for me multiplayer is a lot more fun
when they're playing with you know a
couple friends just enjoying that that
social experience
so that plays a part in into it as well
you are crazy today yeah oh oh you saw
that guy right oh yeah are you kidding
me I think you just had to let it let it
toast a little bit you know let the fire
take effect they don't burn right away
I'm taking Baker
so expeditionary this is where he gets
four incendiary shotgun bullets whoa
these ladders suck her life so to speak
you're on fire and you died or robbed
like I said you could try that
it's very intense [ __ ] the other tactic
I told rob he could try doing with
expeditionary I haven't played it too
much is like shoot on one time with your
incendiary and then like maybe follow up
melee if they're closer switch the
pistol really quick and just like one
tap them I like am I going to die like
right after I like that strap oh oh
lordy I like that strap sniping if
you're good it's quick scoping it's very
good in this game from what I've seen in
multiplayer yeah that scream is legit
though horrifying it's definitely like
it's definitely the most scream like
it's the most horrifying scream you
could probably produce like I I don't
that's like I wouldn't wish that on to
anyone's dead already
just let it be come on in this party
come on in it's party come on in it's
party party party party
boots on the ground we're going to war
Oh dark devil says try aiming the
shotgun that'll reduce this bullet
spreading from spreading in world of war
you could drive tanks and multiplayer I
think that was a Call of Duty two or
three you don't remember that but yeah
thanks Jose a jalapeno Allen s and Meza
love the vids bro i subbed last week
this is my first time in a stream thanks
for subbing from our vibes and thanks
for tuning in to our live streams we
stream every day at 11 a.m. o Monday
Tuesday Thursday Friday will be us just
playing games here
find out some new stuff maybe starting
to play some you know overwatch more
often games like that and then Wednesday
we have the lobby which is our weekly
talk show where we go over some of the
biggest gaming news reviews that we've
done game just gaming all gaming all the
time gaming in a nutshell yeah turtle
power
so that's a with Rob here as well as
Peter Brown Michael Hardy who's normally
our main host he's actually on a little
bit of a vacation right now so Peters
been hosting so John Luke has gone from
the back of the control room to the set
to talk about some games and then of
course Callie laggy as well so you guys
should check that out let's see some
paratroopers yeah Rob some paratroopers
it's actually gonna be pretty tough he
doesn't have that one was it the the
basic training yeah that allows him to
kind of continue earning killstreaks
yeah I took it off that through death
but you only get one of each but we'll
see maybe he'll get a super crazy sick
run because the paratroopers cost 1250
which pretty much means he's gonna have
to get around 12 kills or defends and
stuff like that seemed interesting I
don't know if you guys saw it but it was
like yeah that happens sometimes
I mean you can leave if you want let's
leave and then I can change it people
want to see it again see what I could
call from what I recall I only saw two
paratroopers come down but maybe there
was more than that
and they kind of split up where they ran
- should I shoot their parachutes - you
can try it apparently that was a pro tip
that was given us I think my dark devil
that's if you're calling in a crate you
can actually shoot it the parachute to
make it come down faster which is pretty
cool I think it froze can you even hit
PS PlayStation 1
ok that works all right I'll go back to
full camera or we could just end it
there - why I'll give you what you want
to call it I'll give you one more let's
do one more
yeah just one last time I gave John Luke
one more he went ham so we'll see all
right good that's good okay cool I'll go
ham then I didn't know you wanted wanted
that okay I want you to go ham okay
I can do that what am I gonna eat for
lunch today it's good question I am
thinking I got to think about that - at
some point not sure a lot of options
hot Rob wants that infamous twitch clip
yeah that our twitch clip yesterday
should have been in that one where he
popped off after you want around and
then he couldn't even see his head
anymore he had lost it at that point
last time it's expected yeah twitch
there was a couple people on Twitter
didn't like that don't do that ever
again they said okay so you can switch
it let's watch it with yes which is
basic training - requisitions now he
only earns one of each of his kill
streaks but his kill streaks will
continue to keep like leveling or
progressing through the match despite
dying here do we go
not says we should get Pizza Pizza
I'm gonna play some hard point to wrap
up the stream send it Rob
all your positive energy so that he can
slay and go ham on people straight ham
them send me exactly he's a perfect day
for some a ham says two five six I love
it mm-hmm it is I love it
all these privates dude wait that can't
be right
kiss Ilan says back to its roots sort of
yeah to him or her not even close the
setting maybe but that's it it's still a
SMG dominated piece of green at least it
multiplayer but not at not in war mode
though no non worthless in more
traditional and that's another reason
why war mode is cool right like you you
get to like switch things on the fly
cool I like the clothes you equip the
troopers as a thing you did right it's a
kill streak hmm yeah okay hello what's
the anti cheat - will gonna be on PC
version don't know Skeeter that's why I
never played Cod PC it's always worried
about hackers alright Rob here we go
yeah
show me your best
stab them in the boot I've been doing
the the yeah try to NAS most Cod people
are probably just gonna buy god speed
that although there are some games
coming out ripe affords which might you
know impact a person's wallet October
27th is like a death day for games or
it's a good game for games good day for
games rather sorry because we have
Assassin's Creed origins you got Mario
hurt not Mario hasn't read origin yeah
Mario Odyssey and Wolfenstein that is a
day of games
Wolfenstein do what if he times oh
what's wrong this guy
that was a weird weenie almost did the
sneaky sneaks you should suppress it bro
all right go quiet you don't need to go
hot I saw that guy did he see you though
gotta get that hardpoint oh good night
I like how you check I'm learning for
extra spawners Oh like what I mean that
was a good time right yeah yeah I wasn't
sure if I saw someone when you crouched
someone shooting at me all right new
hardpoint he's a sneaky one
all right so new hard point you guys are
trying to you know obviously contest it
oh oh
made it like didn't show up well because
he cooked it oh it so there's a delay
when that happens so if he cooks it it
pretty much instantly blows up right and
basically it showed on your mini-map for
like a hot second and then god I
shouldn't have done this you can't help
it can't help what you can't help Rob
new hardpoint
it's a pretty good reason dark devil to
kind of swap from ps4 to from PC to the
old way here Holly here and look in the
corner and you'll forget about it is
that so right in front of you do you
laugh oh my god
I thought that was my dude oh my god
sorry I don't know I was drinking we
could all see Digital founder news
coverage of titanfall 2 Xbox one X
enhancements 4k sticky with loads of new
effects and basically definitive edition
that's pretty sick I'm sure Rob will be
into that
what was it I'm sorry digital foundry
did coverage of titan falls to xbox 1x
enhancements oh I want to see that yeah
4k 6000 you stun somebody it's all about
sticking on the hardpoint Oh close uh
there's still I wouldn't I don't know if
there's like spawn trapping but there's
still some all your legs are gone
there's still like you can find some
spawns though I haven't really been able
to chop anyone maybe in combination
though Patrick Baird asking does it feel
different to other Cod's I mean in
setting yes
and some of the minor changes with like
divisions and whatnot yes
and warm oh it's different a lot faster
yeah I would think so maybe not that
much Oh sick recon would've been nice if
you just got paratroopers yeah I've got
a ways to go get to work
you're supposed to go ham god damn it
all right I'm not gonna talk anymore
it's okay you do you know Rob didn't
blow himself up all right he's on his
favorite spot mg nest their game arts
killer really no point
right now goob the highest kill streak
is paratroopers in the current
multiplayer beta so that's the longest
one we know of so far nah I know I think
both of us can't remember what it felt
like to play that game so we can't speak
to that as well man that guy's already
sitting there waiting for you oh yeah we
got to see it once so far in stream
maybe Rob can get it again I see maybe
I bought is an enemy's hunt alrighty
at 25 because is there anything special
that we get I'm not sure I haven't
gotten 25
I think we're out forgot to go ham let
him know so we can clip it yeah Rob
gotta go ham baby all right
he's going into quiet mode to try to go
ham and then once he gets the ham moment
you'll hear him ham it up cat very no no
friendly fire in just standard there
isn't hardcore
move they're smart they're not
I would shot him too because there was
shots fired from that spot earlier [ __ ]
god dude doing it up I haven't been
throwing back the bombs in a hurry corny
yeah yeah
I always forget I just panic and try to
run Wow
rob is not about the objector so he's
here to team deathmatch oh we've got the
Molotov my grenades aren't I oh that's
weird I don't know how that other guy
didn't seem like you could see you
there's no hardcore team deathmatch
currently knows John T Bray what do you
guys think of the maps I as I wasn't as
impressed by them I think this is my
favorite of the three maps I don't know
if that's just because I played it the
least and because visually yeah it's the
coolest but Tyrrell big fan of Gibraltar
I mean the other maps actually not bad
don't just trenches yeah I think they're
fine all close quarters more or less
I'm not even remotely close all right uh
you're like 800 off so I mean don't you
get points for hardpoint stuff oh my god
I'm real real bad today
now you're fine I was doing all right
and now I lost it can't sometimes that
happens you hit a wall living that card
life abysmal you need to relax there
with the wording there what's he saying
I suck
Oh
yeah see that's why I find it really
tough to use this gun without a scope
yeah I was sure I swapped some
attachments that I don't know if I agree
with the drum is fine but
Wow I saw that guys like left-side blown
off holy crap
alright we're back I felt like you were
gonna ride that wave close post one new
hard point so basically for you guys for
you to get your paratroopers you
basically got a stall right now and hold
these hard points for as long as you can
cuz if they get it you're definitely not
getting paratroopers dick oh surprise I
have a friend yeah what she said here we
go
got the hardpoint back Eric you should
have played the last one like last time
you just gotta focus can't get
frustrated
even though cottage in a struggle around
oh we good what Wow look at that pose I
misread open it sleep stick hello oh yes
see this is when the molotovs I think is
it good no for sure
real good kill streak multi sorry coach
for you guys
all right you're so close you're like
240 away I don't know if you're gonna
get it off though you gotta get some
kills like right now and your guys got
to get off the hardpoint
good we're done almost you almost got
the paratroopers guys we got it once
today well if you if you just joined you
can caught you can dial back and find
yeah you could DVR back
it's definitely back there um but yeah
thank you guys all for tuning in um as
me and Rob playing Call of Duty day too
my ear hurts we got this giveaway I'm
gonna pimp it one more time
Oh Oh for this hot zombie poster Oh
follow gamespot twitter and retweet it I
mean you are in the United States you
have a chance at winning this
apparently there's only 3000 of these I
guess I'm looking at the bottom left
right now you can't see it but there's
like a 1816 of 3000 so it looks like
it's a limited run a pretty cool poster
if you're into zombies kind of gruesome
so if you're scared of these kind of
things maybe don't enter but uh we
really appreciate you guys tuning in
we're live every day at 11:00 as I
mentioned before if you haven't subbed
that'll help notify you of when we go
live and also when we put up that hot
rod content so anyways we'll see you
guys on Monday for destiny - PC and
really appreciate you guys tuning in
with us see you guys all later thanks
Rob thanks so much thank you for talking
away man it really helped keep the
attention not on me in my plane but
there we go
peace out push